what's your question and then I can  someone said something about being  selfish wait wait wait bro like if a  woman has 100 control over who get or  who gets born right yeah you have no  control of that so yeah I understand so  if you so if a woman gets pregnant yes  and and you want that baby I have no  saying that okay cool and then if you  don't want that baby you still have no  say in it yeah how is that not 100  controlled and selfish no I'm saying if  the girl wants to have the baby right  how is that selfish if she has a baby  and she feels like it's right what if  you don't no because I don't have any  control in this stuff  to have sex with someone and I'll take  all the responsibilities I'm having sex  with you if I have a baby with you then  I'm gonna take older  they can have to you if you don't want  to you though and she decides to have to  you but my [ __ ] you have sex without  others